I love you more boys who's doing?
Why would you do that when you're on guys?
That's so distracting.
Let's take another.
Time off for what?
For what?
Kind of sucks.
This is our first Olympic break, isn't it?
I know, but the first time it was...
Oh, so is that JT over there?
Yeah.
I don't know why they're doing that.
They're just gonna move on, eh?
Why are we winning?
Yeah, I think you're right.
I think you're right.
You voted over, he's like, I think you guys need more.
I'm like, yo, we're okay.
No, no, no, you need more.
You need two or two.
I got it.
Dang it.
Come on, .
You can miss it.
I got it.
You got it.
Come on, .
Get it.
You can miss it, hang on, it's missable, but he should make it, he should make it, pretty calm wind out here tonight, wind shouldn't be much of a problem for him here, as you can see, hosts are pretty calm, the approach, right down the middle.
He's him.
No, I mean, that, the one, yeah, I don't know how it was, I thought he was diving, yeah, I thought he was diving for it, yeah, I don't know what's going on, you guys got to blow that rock up.
Here he goes, come on, TRD, TRD right home, no support, he's playing in the rock, sir.
Are you aware of what's going on?
He's off, he's off, he's off.
Get her.
Disrupt, disrupt, disrupt.
Yeah.
Wrong guy, wrong guy.
Yo.
Oh, yeah.
That's pretty good.
Let's go, let's go, make a play.
What?
So, he was yellow.
He's a yellow card player.
Did he say something to the ref.
You think he said something to the ref.
Who's the man?
.
Imagine being .
Oh, you've got to get that.
Good kick.
Great kick, actually.
Thank you.